hey everyone welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie today we're going to
do some routing with node and Express
and we had a pull request from Nikki aka
rook in the live chat and I don't think
Nikki's gonna be able to make it to this
chat but we're gonna go over that pool
request I had mentioned yesterday some
of the things I needed to do with the
routing Nikki reminded me that there was
already a pull request there that was
trying to fix the same problems so
apologies to Nikki for me forgetting
about that but I did review the pull
request I have it on a branch here
locally and it looks good it looks I
think it's gonna solve all the problems
that I was talking about yesterday so
we're gonna merge that into the master
branch and we're gonna try it out with
some of our more difficult routes make
sure everything works alright I'm also
going to take you through the logic of
it and we're gonna try to find any areas
where we could make it faster more
efficient where we could clean up the
code if if at all possible and that's
the plan for today I do want to let you
all know well we're kind of waiting for
viewers to get here that I received a
job offer yesterday afternoon so I'm not
gonna share details at least not right
now so anyway so I received a job offer
so I have a lot of thinking to do about
that but I know that some of you have
been following my kind of process of
interviewing and things like that so I
just wanted to give you an update
yeah so I will I will be giving you more
updates as things happen and Blake asks
if it's a bigger company I guess I think
like in terms of total employees I don't
think it's as big as the University but
like geographically it's more spread out
so there are multiple locations where
does the university is mainly just one
location with I mean we do have a campus
in Austria so I guess it's two all right
ib shik is asking about CSS we're not
gonna do a lot with CSS today but we do
use CSS you know somewhat frequently so
if you check out some of the other
streams as well we'll get into that but
you know if you want to stick around
today we're you know we are gonna do a
lot a lot of other stuff Blake asked if
it's a web developer job yeah yeah it is
you know basically doing a lot of the
same stuff I'm doing right now I'd still
be working with react which is cool
all right well let's get started and
mites all right so now you should be
able to see my screen if you want to
check out the pool requests that we're
about to merge you can go to the
repository under pool requests currently
it's the only pool request that is not
merged so it'll be easy to find and the
particular file that we're really
worried about right now is server j/s so
we're gonna spend all of our time in
server dodge as there are a few other
things that think need will probably end
up just getting rid of them because
there was some test things here like you
can see hat and hat list Jas so there
are some test things just so that Nikki
could illustrate near the new features
that he built into this pool request
so we'll probably get rid of those at
some point today let me start my
Pomodoro session so for those of you who
are new I'm not sure how the stream goes
I break things up by Pomodoro session so
I will start this clock it'll be 25
minutes for 25 minutes we're going to go
through the code I'm gonna not really
look at the live chat that much during
that time so I will glance at it
occasionally but after that 25 minutes
is up I'm gonna take a five-minute break
go back to the live chat and go through
all your questions and comments and then
we're going to do another 25 minute
session of code after that the whole
rest of the stream will be question and
answer so if you ask a question and I'm
not getting into it right away please be
patient and I will get to it
you know within you know the longest you
have to wait is is till the end of the
stream I suppose and if you can't stick
around to hear the answer you can always
watch the recording and for those of you
that already watching the recording
later on you can ask me questions as
well in the comment
below and or in any type of social media
that you like I'm on pretty much all the
the main social media channels so just
find me somewhere so I can't always get
back to everyone right away but I do try
to get back to everyone at some point
all right so enough about that let's
just get started so I'm not gonna start
and rock yet whenever we get this merge
then I'll start and rock and right now
it's just not I mean I guess we could
start it and it would work all right so
what I've done so far I've made no
changes to the code manually but I've
just merged what we had in master
because master was a little bit farther
ahead than this this pull request so I
merged everything in master into this
alt router branch the OL trout er branch
is not in the repo right now and I won't
push it to the repo because we're gonna
merge it right now it'll be part of
master so what did change from what's in
the pool requests are some of the the
routes in here see so we we have a route
name search that will be in there so
just a few minor changes so I'm gonna
increase the font size make some room
and then step through what's going on
and then that way as we step through it
maybe we can get an idea for ways to
improve it although nothing against
nakey this is really genius I love this
but if there's a way to make it faster
refactor it a bit then we should take
the opportunity because this is a key
function every single visit is going to
go through this function for every page
view so if we're gonna find one spot
where refactoring is gonna have the most
value it'll be here so anything we can
do just to make it just a little bit
faster will have a huge impact you know
when
multiplied by all the visits you know
which will get which which will be
millions over the course of I think over
the course of a year we're getting I
don't know four or five million visits
so you know it's not like we're you know
top ten site in the world or anything
like that but it's a lot of visits okay
so here's our object so if you have been
watching when we've done things about
the router earlier then you you know
what's going on here
but if you haven't basically this object
we're listing a lot of routes so this
value here is what's going to come in
through the URL so in this case you know
I'm doing this locally so it's localhost
3000 slash if you went to slash faculty
we're saying go to that component the
page component called faculty that's
what we want to render and the data type
is faculty so we're telling the router
what component to send this data to and
then we're telling it the data that
actually needs sent and then with that
it's going to go through a graph QL
query to WordPress it's gonna get the
data when the data comes back the
component will render and then the user
will be able to see the data the reason
that we are doing it like this and it
looks I mean it looks a little messy
right honestly is because we have to
keep all the routes all the URLs the
same from the current site the old site
to this new one that we're making so in
order to do that you know we need a lot
of control over what the routes are so
we couldn't just use a built-in routing
solution that comes with next chasse you
know or even you know trying to use a
different routing solution you know may
or may not have worked but it would have
required a lot of customers
so we're just you know basically doing
everything custom you know within
express within our server dodge as file
one thing that I think would be good as
this gets bigger is to put this into its
own file and just import it in so that's
actually maybe I'll make an issue about
that and then that'll be a really nice
like very easy pool request for somebody
to get if you're looking to get some
pool request you're getting a profile
especially if it'll be like your first
pull request so maybe I'll save that as
an issue all right so let's to actually
step through what happens when you go to
somewhere on the site so we'll go
through an easy example first so if we
go to slash search let's just assume we
went to slash search it would go here
and you know server get would fire off
and we would do we're checking
parameters right so in this case we only
have this first parameter okay so the
other ones there's there's not going to
be anything there right we are making
sure all the parameters go to lower case
and
yeah okay so if the parameter exists
which is pretty much every page except
the home page then we're going to take
it you know put it to lowercase
otherwise it's going to be null and it's
the same thing for each parameter so
it's either going to be null or it's
going to be the lowercase version of
that part of the URL we do have some
things that we want to we don't want to
do anything to in terms of custom
routing so any files that have these
parameters we're just going to let them
pass right through and we're not gonna
do custom routing otherwise we're gonna
go down here and we have a few things so
we have this default page route and
that's just kind of a it has minimal
styles
it's our default component to display
data we do have more specialized
components to display certain types of
data we also have our site if the user
doesn't specify a type they're going to
take the parameter and then just add
pages onto the end of it and that will
be the type okay we've done it like this
because this is the naming convention
that I'm using for data types for for a
lot of the data types not all of them
make sense to do it like that but enough
of them do that this is a good default
and will save us you know some space in
our object and then the subtype and the
ID or no for now and they will be given
a value if they exist in this case when
we're just doing the search route they
they don't exist so actually let me let
me know if anyone's still there I
haven't seen anything in the live chat
for a while and that's weird
everyone's usually more talkative so
it's showing that there are viewers but
there we are
okay that's something new I was afraid
that the the stream cut out or something
okay let's see all right hopefully y'all
are still with me let me know if I need
to explain something else you know over
again if it's not clear so now we're
really getting into the logic of things
here so we're gonna filter out this is
kind of interesting let me make this a
bit bigger as well okay so we have an
object right and normally you don't use
filter on an object you use filter on an
array so what object got values does and
we're doing that on our params object
that values returns an array of the
values of the object so objects are our
objects have key value pairs we are just
getting the values and then we're
filtering and we want to know if the
length is equal to 1 all right why 1
because 1 we were checking for one
parameter and the the comments in here
that that Nickey put in here are really
good to explain what's going on so we're
actually this will pass this this if
statement will pass for what we have
right now and if we had two or three
parameters it would fail and we pass to
the next one so
if if they find so we're looking in that
translation object so if we find as a
key the name of that which would be
searched which is in our translation
object then we'll do what's in here so
we're gonna get that search and then
page right so within our search key we
have a value so we basically have
another object in there and then we have
another key called page the value of
that is going to be the component that
we want to render this to and in this
case we want to render it to the
component name search okay so it's gonna
find that and then it's going to check
for this next if statement so if the
value of page actually I'm sorry first
it's just checking if this exists so I
was I was getting ahead of myself
so it's just checking to see if the page
value exists for that then it's checking
to see if the page value is an object if
it is an object we want to get the
default value for the object and this is
some of the new stuff that's been at it
in Bini key in this last pull request so
what we're doing by making the page
giving the page the option to be an
object is that we can have the same
route render to different components
depending on the number of parameters so
if it's one parameter it does the
default but in this case we don't have a
default on search so we're gonna drop
down to this else statement so if there
isn't a default but there's still a
value there then it's just a string so
we're just going to take that string so
the value of page now becomes slash
search the string slash search
and we drop down to find our type and in
this case I don't believe we have do we
have the type let me double check our
objects I don't think we have one no we
don't so in this case with search we
don't have a type we don't have an ID so
it's just gonna pass down right we're
gonna pass over that elsif over that
else--if okay we're gonna pass all the
way down to here and we're gonna render
in cash and we're sending all the data
that we need and where's a rendering
cache there we are so within this
function I'm not gonna go over this
because this is a new stuff but
basically we're checking to see if we
have that cast already the actual markup
rendered and cached on the the react
that the node server where this lives if
we do have a caster Rd great we just
serve that up no need to go grab the
data anywhere no need to re render it
just goes right out this is best-case
scenario the user is gonna get a near
instantaneous response if it's not cash
though then we're gonna send it through
we're gonna render we're going to call
this render to HTML and so we're gonna
send all those query params and then
that's when everything's gonna happen
like I explained at the beginning where
you know graph QL query is gonna go get
some data from WordPress and then it's
gonna render so the only difference if
we had more parameters is that it would
skip over that first if statement and
would drop down to this else else if if
we have two parameters and then it would
get let's see there's a second frame
coming to play
okay there we go so something with two
parameters then gets this value of we
grab the page standard so instead of the
default page we want to render this
using a different component which we're
going to give the key of standard and
then if there are three it looks like
this isn't finished yet so I don't think
Nikki has finished this part yet so you
know we'll need to grab we'll find an
example of something that's three
parameters we'll copy and paste a lot of
this and then set it up see if we can
get the three parameter thing to work
okay I feel like I need to take a breath
after that let me take a drink I have my
G fuel handy as I usually do and alright
I'm gonna quickly check the live chat to
see if I lost anyone okay
it looks good so in about ten minutes
I'm going to come back and answer
questions in in the live chat right now
what I'd like to do is find a route I
want to find a route where we're
actually going to use some of this
functionality and then we're gonna build
out the rest of it so I guess we could
this is entirely functional right now so
let me merge this with master push it to
github and then you'll have everything
there to look at all the code so let's
do that now so I'm gonna go back check
out so we're going to check out master
now we're on the master branch and I'm
gonna do a git merge and we're going to
merge that alts
router branch I've already merged master
indle router so there should be no merge
conflicts going the other way I always
recommend doing that so that you can
test everything out while you're still
on that that branch I think it just
makes things a lot easier especially if
there there is you know there are weird
things going on I mean if if nothing
weird happens it probably takes a little
bit longer but it's worth it in case it
messes everything up then you can just
abandon that branch start over much less
of a mess so let's merge awesome we
merged everything went well and now I'm
gonna do git push so now all of this new
code is there and I said there is some
stuff to clean up so we may or may not
get to that the actual clean up stuff
because that's not really exciting it's
a stream so if you do notice at some
point that things still need cleaned up
and you'd like to get an easy pull
request you know feel free to do that I
just I'd like to help you all who maybe
haven't gotten very many pool requests
in or none at all to be able to have you
know get your first pull request in and
get your practice in on something like
this where we can I can help guide you
through it if if needed and then you
know build up your confidence a bit and
then you can go off to other open source
projects and you know and work on those
is I know it's really intimidating to
get that first pool request in on you
know someone else's project alright so I
need to go let me find I think I had a
window open on my other screen that was
a good example of the
yes I do all right
all right let me check this page out so
academics undergrad majors currently
works and that has three parts let's see
where I have it going right now so I
think I had two I think I had to mess
things up a little bit to make it work
actually let me I do want to restart
this too just to make sure occasionally
I have trouble when making big shifts
between branches that some of the old
code it remains so before I started
doing anything I'm going to check this
out okay
all right so for that academics page is
working
what about our other academics pages
okay no wait let's try to the our other
academics pages so in our drawer if we
should have a list of all the links in
that side drawer and that's what we need
to change here to do our tests sure menu
[Music]
bar so data yeah it is your menu okay
all right so under academics you can see
here we're passing in undergraduate so
here's the URL that is typed in and then
we're passing in here as page type
academics pages ID majors okay cool so
we are passing in everything that we
need here so let's try passing in what
we need from from this one so yeah page
type academics pages ID graduate
graduate programs
the reason we're doing it like this has
to do with our client-side routing so
you wouldn't always have to do this
all right let's save that and come back
here and click this now okay can't
really you know that undefined all right
I was kind of hoping we got an error I
didn't want it to it's not as fun when
everything just works all right so first
thing to check is within WordPress make
sure that we actually have a page that
fits this description
we may not that might be the source of
our error okay almost time to go back
and answer questions okay cool so that's
working my phone keeps thinking that I'm
talking to it and it keeps coming up
with you know the Google thing Google
assistant alright cool so that is
working awesome when we come back I'm
gonna try to solve I'm gonna try to load
some pages that I've been having issues
with and make sure that our solution can
handle that because I was I was wasting
significant brainpower on trying to
figure something out the last day or two
so that's what we'll go to if if it
passes that test let's say then I'm
really confident that this will work for
us so we can move on and build out what
we need if we happen to get three three
parameters in our URL okay so it when we
just did this it was I don't want to say
it was a little bit of a cheat but we
were feeding the router exactly what we
wanted what we want to do we're gonna do
next though is users are gonna put in a
route and it could be essentially like
we won't be feeding the router the ID
and the type and everything like we're
doing in that list so we want to make
sure it can still pick out these
different parameters and go where it
needs to go
oh and I lost the live chat window where
is it
okay I found it I have live chat windows
open for the last two weeks of streams I
really really need to clean up my my
tabs as soon as I update Chrome the wall
go away okay let me set this short break
and scroll up and get to the chat it's
kind of quiet in the chat today and I
that's not necessarily a bad thing
oh cool I have so mad Dutchess says
congratulations thank you if you missed
it at the beginning I got a job offer
for for a job last yesterday right at
the end of my day at my work day I got a
job offer so I'm considering it among
other opportunities so I'll keep you all
up to date on you know what happens and
how it's gonna affect the stream but I
just wanted to share that with you all
since you've kind of been with me along
this whole process of interviewing and
things let's see
Blake asks what do you think about view
as it looks simpler than reacts I
haven't used view so my opinion on you
is not going to be very reliable let's
say but I've seen enough def so that I
respect and that do good work using view
that I can be you know pretty sure that
view is a solid product and I think it's
a good alternative to reacts for
whatever reason you met you may not want
to use react so can't speak from
experience but from what I do know I I
think it's it looks promising it looks
good I'm sorry I was a little distracted
the head of my department just sent me a
text okay when when your boss's boss
messages you you got a you got to read
it see Omar says the beard looks nice
thank you I appreciate it it's getting a
little bit longer I'm gonna get it
trimmed tomorrow I'm gonna go get a
haircut and the beard trimmed up so it's
not gonna be that much shorter but it's
just not gonna look at scruffy I did
comb it this morning so I appreciate you
noticing it's getting to the point now
where I wake up and it's it's like wild
and it looks crazy so if I don't comb it
it's I mean it really looks like puffed
out and wild Mohammed asks what software
I use I'm using Visual Studio code as my
code editor and my terminal that you can
see in the background is I term - hey
Nicki's here awesome
Nicki I thought you had family coming
over hopefully if your family comes
please don't watch the stream anymore
hang out with your family if you are
still here though I just want to let you
know that your your pull request is
awesome I really really like what you've
done I'm I'm pretty sure it's gonna
solve all the problems so really really
good work I very much appreciate it it
just took a big load off of me that I
kept thinking of how I was gonna make
this work not realizing that you had
already solved it so thank you again
craftsman oh six says can you shout on
my channel sure so I assume your channel
is just craftsman oh six so there's your
shoutout I don't know what your channel
was about so I I can't really recommend
it to anybody
since I have no idea what it's about but
if anybody's interested in you know
figuring out what that channel is check
out craftsman oh six bosses here hails
us how's it going see John's here how's
it going John well Leeds here Wow
hey I'm Justin say hey to everybody
there's a lot of people saying hi are in
it in a sense that's great news thanks
Anna yeah it is it's it's great I have a
lot of decisions to make now so I'm
really happy to be in this predicament
of having to really think and make some
decisions now it's a good problem to
have
so yeah it's it's exciting
Jason says congrats you thank you old
sauce also says congrats says is this
the job where you had a three hour long
interview it is it is that one I begun
to think that I wasn't gonna get an
offer because a decent amount of time
had gone by and I hadn't heard anything
so it was a very good surprise when I
got that it was right at the end of
yesterday stream raid at the end of the
stream I got
during the stream I think but I just
hadn't checked my email then and as soon
as I ended the stream I checked my email
quickly before I had my next meeting and
I just saw it briefly got a chance to
just scan through a little bit before my
next meeting and then I was sitting
through this other meeting just like I
couldn't wait to come back and read
through everything about the about the
offer so anyway my timer is up so Mahmud
says hello from Turkey ah so you do it
awesome thank you thank you I appreciate
it and welcome
let's see jason says decisions on
framework seemed to come down to team /
project rather than features one has
over another yeah honestly it there's a
lot of different decision decision
points that go into what tech you're
going to use what stack you're going to
use so yeah I guess it's not always just
simply about let's compare feature by
features so yeah there's a lot of them
I've had to make a lot of decisions on
what stack we're gonna use and there
there is a lot more involved so luckily
I've been able to kind of work my way to
a point where I have a lot of freedom
with the stack this tech stack that I
choose and a lot of people are in that
position so I do appreciate that I'm in
a nice position there it's not
everybody's in okay let's go back let's
reset this timer we're gonna get in at
least one more moment or a session and
CNN video says I'm new how are you I'm
doing really well today how are you
doing also welcome thanks for watching
and that's going to be the last comment
that I read until after this next
session all right so we tried out a few
routes now here is where the the bigger
test is gonna
to play so let me I'm still trying to
find on my other screen the routes that
were giving me problems okay I think I
found one all right so in our server dot
j s file we have theology and right now
it goes to the page major to render with
the type of majors okay all right
I've we are gonna have to modify this
this function so what I need is just
like how we can have multiple IDs and
pages we need to be able to have
multiple types I do I need the ability
to pull from different post types all
right so let's let's do that so right
now what this is doing is if you go to
the page slash theology it pulls the the
post type with the the slug of majors or
I'm sorry with the slug of theology from
the post type majors and it renders that
using the component major but then
what's going to happen is we're gonna
have a route and it'll be slash theology
slash like online Associates is one of
the routes what the the problem that is
there is online Associates is going to
exist as a
from post type so it's not it doesn't
belong in the the majors post type so
that's where we need a change so let's
go down here and see what we need to do
apologies for the awning that's you only
need to do to make that happen i I just
I kept thinking it's this is so easy
it's everything's working I knew it I
knew we were forgetting something and so
let's see where this is so the type so
we're grabbing a default ID second frame
all right so we're definitely going to
do this in the second per am spot it
makes no sense to do it with the first
program so second program and where we
have the type okay so the type now is
going to be an object so let's grab all
of this copy it
now you know what I don't think I'm
gonna copy it all because I wanna oh
yeah I guess I can let's copy that and
let's paste it here below this so we're
gonna have to change everything here to
type all right so all of that is tight
and then let's keep this standard
all right let's use that and so that way
it'll be easier to kind of tell like
okay if we have two params for both page
and type it's both gonna be standard we
may end up changing yeah maybe we can
change that so Niki had mentioned about
like the naming he wasn't really sure
about the naming so for now I'm just
gonna keep it the same because we all
know the hardest part of coding is
deciding what to name things well let's
just keep it the same and let's remove
this now and now what we should be able
to do is go up here and put in or as I
add theology so let's do it like this
let's say we're gonna use the page type
a major actually you know what I do want
to keep it as major so I just glanced at
how this page is structured on the
current site I think we're gonna
structure the same way but we are gonna
change the type so Rd we're gonna have
to do a default side too are we yeah
okay
the full type is majors and our standard
type is going to be theology pages and
we haven't even made this type yet so
I'm to test this really I'm gonna have
to go to make that I suppose okay
and then our ID
all right we're gonna need let's let's
see I need to go back down and see how
we're handling IDs to see if we need to
change this but for now I think this
will work
we do need to add something to make this
default word see if I'm jumping around
too much please let me know if once I do
this and we see if it works I will go
back and you'll explain more but I'd
rather not explain something that's
broken in that way you know I may be
misleading someone and I'd rather not do
that
so our default
okay we need to add default type here so
let's take our type and since we're now
using standard and default there we are
okay
all right that should work and let's see
what's going on with the ID shows our
first program ID first second to him
okay so we are going to get the the
correct idea
it looks like that'll be fine we won't
have to change anything so I'm gonna
save that save that route let's I guess
very quickly add theology pages let's
see where I I don't think I brought that
data in anywhere but if I have already
it will save us some time let me just
take a second to look
so on my other screen I have my
WordPress admin panel open if you really
want to see that let me know but
otherwise I'm just searching for this
content within the admin panel
this may be under sociated programs now
hmm
okay I don't think I have this here
all right um how much let's see if I
have enough time I think we have enough
time for this to work
maybe or we could just try a different
page where I already have all the data
how about that
okay so first let me see
sorry I just quit talking the middle of
a sentence okay so I double-checked we
do have some data that should work
I'm just changing yeah changing the slug
so it will work for us okay so I'm gonna
test the route just to double-check that
it won't work with our current system
whoops what it works okay
how does it work
I guess who's it as the same
content-type all right how about this
alright here's what I'm gonna do since
I'm having trouble finding a suitable
piece of content to test this with and I
don't want to take up the rest of our
time in data transfer which is really
boring
let's build out the rest of what we know
we need and this is this is weird
do we really need that
now I'm wondering do we really need
these this part yet
like how did this what I'm wondering is
how did this even work
all right let me try out a few pages to
see what's working and what's not
working
I forgot these links are not gonna work
for us yes we can make sure some links
still work
okay there's a route that's usually -
and that still works I think we did some
of these routes
okay so here's one that okay so it's
it's giving us this page isn't giving us
an error but it's not taking us anywhere
else so it's giving it this should be
the page URLs admissions Franciscan
difference undergraduate but what is
giving us is the same page as if you
went to the URL admissions undergraduate
so it looks like it's ignoring that
second bit and just giving us the first
two so we will need that third you know
this third one here and we need a way to
handle those routes I wish our URL
structure were different but this is
what we have so we have to make this
work
so let's go now all right okay so we
have our filter here three parameters
page first for him so type second for
him okay
all right so let's see where I need to
go from from here to here
all right so we'll start by a copy and
pasting you know what we what we already
have and then we just need to modify it
a bit so we're gonna instead of standard
let's say thirdly this it doesn't really
matter at this foot so see the ID is
gonna be third per am right and the
tight
the first frame is still under graduated
I'm sorry that's it says their friend
Heidi say
alright let me go go check the live chat
quickly see if anybody has any ideas for
this Shanxi modification Association AHA
Jackson
okay five minutes okay let's see let's
walk through this and see what we need
in this specific case let's check and
see where this this content lives at in
in WordPress
hmm
okay so currently this content has has
come in under the same content type as
the rest of the admissions pages so
let's see what rain in admissions pages
I think it's up here
oh we're not even doing anything okay
that makes more sense as to why it
worked okay yeah so admissions phages
we're working fine without even having
to put them in in the object because
they fit the default pattern for tight
and they use the default component so we
didn't need anything in there so since
since that was the case it would always
just take whatever the last thing is as
the ID okay so we are gonna have to
change that so let's grab something that
probably end up being similar
a few departments
you
all right let's do that and let's put it
down here let's say let's get rid of
hats right now while we're at it okay so
this would be admissions
page they page like the admissions pages
ID the fault of admissions I don't even
know if we have a page that's just
admissions
oh hey we do
okay so yeah so by default it'll just
say admissions otherwise what was the
other one standard alright so if it's if
we don't have a standard ID how do we
use that standard ID before with
theology right tell G pages just in your
type
all right with this change let's see
what works and what doesn't work okay so
that doesn't work now which makes more
sense
okay
all right so that's not working now
commissioners case I page the admissions
pages
- two parameters
second program is the ID
okay this should be fun it should be
getting the right site and then don't ID
as I should have a second for him
okay so it's not working I guess because
of the ID thing
so alright so I think it can't handle
right now the ID as an object so we're
we're just going to change this up a bit
so that I can handle that
whoops ID and this is gonna be standard
and now we can get rid of this and I'm
ready
okay
I'll shred it out now see if we can get
this to work
No
okay so if JD objects
during else
oh you know what I'm not we need to add
in more checks
all right let me go back to the live
chat here and because my my point over
time I ran out
okay so let me let me just explain
quickly what the next step needs to be
and why this isn't working and then I'm
gonna go back to the live chat and
answer all your questions so what we've
done is we've given it the ability to
handle the ideas and object and the
check for the ID you know dot standard
but what happens if there is an ID
object but there isn't an ID dot
standard so in that case what we need to
do here is after we do this this check
you know if it is the type of objects
and we could probably just put an an
here and there is this ID standard that
exists then what we want to do is set
the type to standard if that's not the
case though so we need a else here I
guess we already have the else going
here so if there is the standard type
equals first frame ID okay so this one
was checking to make sure we could still
use a string as the ID so that's not
100% necessary we could potentially
always have an object then that would be
okay
so just for demonstration purposes let's
take this out so let's say else meaning
there is no stand there is an object but
there's no standard key on that object
type is going to equal second / am
let's say that and see if I know what
I'm doing
no and I don't I don't know what I'm
doing unfortunately
cannot create a feel an undergraduate on
type root query
he
yep not sure what I did there now so we
won in the right place here go on the
right place here this should just be
ignored
hmm
wait a second the IDS already second
program
so we're still in there is an ID and
then if it is an object and there is
standard it does this let's take this
back for a second
yeah so that wasn't gonna run because
we're saying if there is an object so we
need we need to pull this out that was
my mistake that was bad logic on my part
so the idea of what I'm saying works but
I put the in statement I combine those
if statements and I should not have
combined those if statements
sufen is an object we're gonna say they
were going to check to see if this is a
lie if statements then side standard
else
it's gonna be done I don't need the else
right do anything else
let's just put let's put the Elson just
to be sure all right let's see if that
works this is the last thing I'll try
whether or not it works I'm done and I'm
gonna go to the live chat I'm feeling
that point where my brain just needs a
break anyway
one more hard refresh alright didn't
work okay so mission not accomplished
today we did get some things working
that weren't working before and then I
broke some stuff that was working so I
guess kind of a win I mean like all in
all I think there are more pages working
than we had when we started so we can we
can be happy about that
I wish we would have figured out what's
going on here but it's just not gonna
happen right now so I'll work on this
some more today hopefully I'll have it
fixed by tomorrow and if you have any
questions please put them in the live
chat right now I'm scrolling down
through and I will answer everything in
the chat here's a question from Blake I
need a new laptop what should I get
Lenovo ThinkPad vs. Dell XPS 2 1 vs
surface pro 2 3 with at least I 5 8
gigabytes of RAM
mad Duchess says the surface Pro's seems
powerful little experience with it but
look it feel beautiful Dell was always
decent powerful so I'm an HP girl myself
I always have leg on Lenovo no matter
the specs I had Duchess also says Dell
has never let me down I've had four
different lenovo's two laptops and two
desktop
always the same lag issues I'm a bit of
a tech geek I have three Dell machines
all beautiful and powerful never miss a
beat don't have much experience with
surface pro my dad has one and it's nice
but I don't use it enough to give a full
and accurate UX UI opinion on them all
right cool that was super informative
Matt Duchess thank you for that yeah I
don't I've been using Mac's primarily
now for about two and a half years so I
I don't think I'm I've been out of the
PC world for too long the the Microsoft
world for too long to really know what's
going on there John says I just got a
new Lenovo yoga 9 20
set up most of yesterday loved it
installed Visual Studio code just now
impressed love the stylus for my art 16
gigs of ram one terabyte solid-state
drive that's cool congratulations on the
new computer John let's
I'm using
Oh Nikki I didn't realize you you had
switched accounts alright I need to go
back through and read some of this now
realizing that Nikki switched accounts
oh I see now where you told me you
switched accounts it all makes sense now
see there's some more discussion about
different pcs so I'm kind of skipping
over a bit
hi John says I really think today Jessie
you've got my brain fried usually I can
follow I can kind of follow lol yeah
today my brains a bit fried too it's
yeah it's uh this routing stuff has been
really tricky every time I think I
haven't figured out I find a different
URL on the main site that just won't
quite fit with what we have so yeah I'm
gonna I I may actually like draw some of
this out on paper to help me visualize
what's really happening that may help me
yeah that really meant might help me see
the big picture and not mess things up
so that's going to be my next step here
after I in the stream also says how to
use enric in my projects I would I don't
remember exactly how I set it up
initially cuz it's been a while but
check out the instructions on how to use
and grow it's not it's just a
command-line tool so you would in terms
of what you're going with your project
nothing in your project would actually
have to change at all so this would just
run right alongside your project
Zubin says what coding style slash
guideline do you follow I don't see I
see you don't use semicolon your
JavaScript I was following his style
similar to yours and got a hard time
from a co-worker yeah I follow standard
jazz I don't like using the semicolons
seems to me that if there's a character
that doesn't need to be there then it's
inefficient to keep putting it there and
the circumstances where you actually
need a semicolon and JavaScript are very
rare if I were to come across one of the
circumstances
and I would use a semicolon but but I
don't need to so some people are very
strong opinions about semicolon so I
that's probably you know where your
co-worker was coming from there
personally me I it doesn't matter if you
use semicolons or not but if you're
working on my projects and you try to
commit it'll automatically remove the
semicolons so you can do it however you
want and then it's going to get turned
into the way that the standard way that
we're using but yeah the way I see it
you can use them you could not use them
if there's a certain way you have to do
it for a project and yeah follow that
way or set up some sort of automatic
formatting so that you can type however
you want and it'll get formatted the way
it needs to be and it says how was your
day Jesse pretty pretty good so far that
in last night was rough
cordelia my little one she's one and a
half and she was sick and she just
wanted me to cuddle her last night so I
took her and she was just coughing and
up a lot and then you know he got a baby
right next to you trying to sleep was
like I'm always waking up trying making
sure she's okay you know even when she's
still sleeping I'm waking up and I woke
up in the middle of the night and felt
her leg or leg felt really cold and so I
was like freaking out like oh she all
right so I'm trying to listen for a
breathing and I couldn't hear anything
so now I'm really freaking out so then I
like grabbed her and she moved and so I
was of course very relieved but then you
just have that adrenaline rush right so
you it's hard to go back to sleep so I
didn't get that much sleep I still have
my sore throat I don't know if I I
haven't been feeling well unless I guess
it's been a week now just kind of
sorcerer sluggish tired so anyway I woke
up kind of late didn't get my workout in
but I was able to get into work
about quarter after 8:00 a.m. which is
pretty early compared to you know
everybody else in my in my office here
so it's kind of nice to get in like that
and yes I guess it's been a not a bad
day so far yeah I'm feeling good
a little tired but I'm feeling good
otherwise thanks for asking how was your
day a noble and savage says you sexy
bearded coder that's probably the first
time anybody's ever said that phrase to
me congratulations that's you are the
first and I really that's a great way to
describe me I think so anyway hey noble
savage how's it going
[Music]
Matt Duchess says brain fry happens but
it's good it means we have something new
to learn yeah hopefully like when you
work out your muscles get sore and then
they get stronger hopefully your brains
like that too because I'm about to get
really stronger in my brain this my
brain is super fried right now John says
you're gonna have to show us your
artwork the big picture oh if I draw
something up I will show you but it's
it's not gonna be that great my artwork
skills are minimal and that's like
putting it nicely alright well I think
I'm gonna end this dream now and
probably take a little break to rest my
brain before I go back at this let me
think what's going on tomorrow I'm gonna
try to stream tomorrow if I can I have a
couple of meetings and things going on
so
I'll try to I'll try my best to fit in
the stream tomorrow I'm not sure what
time I'll be able to do that yet but
hopefully we will be able to have one
and you think yeah and that's it for me
thank you all so much I really
appreciate all the help thanks for
hanging in there when I was just
confusing my own self and until tomorrow
have a wonderful day